we are in the Faculty room at low
library at Columbia University this room
was originally the East Asian reading
room and later on once the library
itself changed in its history this room
became the gallery for the Sackler art
collections Arthur Sackler was a medical
doctor he and his wife became active art
collectors early in their marriage and
gradually over time in the 1950s they
began to explore East Asian and near
East Asian art gradually over time they
came to Columbia University as one of
their favorite universities in the new
york city area and began actively
collecting with the intent of donating
the collection to columbia university so
that it can be utilized for future study
and display purposes with the Columbia
community and the public at large the
earliest work that's currently on
display in this gallery is a Shang
Dynasty bronze and it roughly dates from
about 1500 BCE so approximately 3500
years ago in this particular work this
lid is almost a complete fascinating
work unto itself and if you can look
closely you see in the center there is
actually a feline creature a sort of
cat-like creature that has been wound
into and coiled and surrounding it there
are dragons meandering in another
pattern these materials all have their
own unique traits because of their
unique features whether it's the
patterns on them or the specific type of
metals that were used in the composition
for some of the bronzes or the actual
decorative components many of the
bronzes for instance were found in
archeological digs and there's a lot of
research still to be done on these and
this continues to happen so the
reinstallation that we have here in the
faculty room is just the beginning
stages of what we hope and envision can
happen for the future many of the cases
as you see them have been changed but
they still need a little bit more work
and we are hoping to be able to do more
in the near future to enhance the
viewing experience of these artworks for
people to see